hey what's going on my name is Alan Dru
and today we are talking about what it
means to be an eale goat in fact I'm
going to give you the five maxims that
make up the email goat Manifesto these
are rules to live by a philosophy of the
email marketer so that's what we're
going to dive into today now I know
you're asking how are you going to be an
email goat and me to be an email goat
how are there going to be all these
email goats there's going to be goats
everywhere it's there not even going to
be grass cuz all these goats are just
hanging around well I used to struggle
with this massively when I got to email
copyrighting I started reading people
like Dan Kennedy and Ben settle and
Eddie Quan and Daniel throssel and I was
like oh my God I'm never going to be
able to keep up with these guys I mean
they are just so much better than me
they're better riters they're funnier
they're hilarious they don't look as
good as me but goly are they better
riters than me and then as I kept
writing so many people kept saying Allan
I love your emails Allan I read your
emails every day and all these things
and don't even know who those guys are
and I started to realize I'm somebody's
goat I'm not the goat but I'm somebody's
email go and I believe that can be the
same for you so as you build your
personal brand with email marketing
email copyrighting you are somebody's
email goat and so I'm going to give you
the five maxims that make up the email
goat Manifesto on how you can be an
email goat to somebody else so let's
Dive Right In maximum number one
relationships over Revenue everything
that we do in email marketing is focused
on relationships you have a segment of
people that you want to serve and the
better you know those people the better
you know their problems what keeps them
up at night what they hope and dream of
all relational aspects the better you
could serve them and the better that you
serve them the more Revenue you get
anyway right revenue is a byproduct of
relationships and on the flip side
people who focus on Revenue over
relationships will struggle in the long
game because they don't have a reason to
continue to buy from you right you do a
flash sale you do things like that but
that's not why people buy from you in
the long run they buy from you in the
long run because they know you and they
trust you and they respect you and you
know how you can help them and you'll
learn way more about your Market you'll
have way more fun doing this you'll
build a strong community and you're
going to sell stuff anyway the second
Maxim that we're going to talk about is
publish over perfect now if we're coming
from relationships over Revenue there's
nothing simpler to transition than
saying well how often are you going to
talk to your people you should talk to
your people every day and they want to
hear the raw authentic dirty version of
everything that you're talking about I
mean not too dirty but you get what I'm
saying here okay they want to hear from
you daily because they want to get to
know you and build a relationship with
you that's why they got on your list so
they can pursue their dreams through you
they can learn from you they can get to
know you and they could buy from you and
you can't do that by sending an email
once a week if I were to tell you that I
talk to my wife once a week you would
probably be like hey this guy's marriage
is probably on the Rocks yeah it
probably is if I'm talking to my wife
once a week but I talk to my wife every
single day and we have a good marriage
and we have three kids which tells you
we have a good marriage sometimes but
you get what I'm saying you want to talk
to your people every day and so you just
got to hit that publish button send that
daily email build those daily
relationships don't worry about the
unsubscribes they should get out of
there anyway Maxim number three that
we're going to lean into to be an email
goat is ugly over beautiful I cannot
stand all these highly designed emails
in fact every time I talk to an email
copywriter they spend 80% of their time
designing the emails even with all these
templates putting the pictures in and
putting the gifts in and the rows and
bro
write the freaking
email write an ugly email plain text one
that you would send to your grandma
because it builds the relationships it
feels one more oneon-one when you design
all these emails and you make them all
beautiful and stuff it feels like a mass
email honestly that feels just like bro
email me oneon-one make it personal
plain text don't even put a button when
you put your stuff put a ugly old
hyperlink hat tip to my man Ben settle
from his email player schema you want
ugly emails you don't want these pretty
fancy emails don't waste your time if
you're going to be somebody's goat
freaking write bro you are a writer you
need a write don't worry about the
design maximum number four human over
robot I can't believe I have to say this
I mean do I really have to say this
don't use chat GPT for any of it okay
don't automate it don't do any of that
because it violates all the rules it
violates all the rules except for ugly
over Beauty because chat gbt is ugly but
it definitely violates the relationship
rule okay how are you supposed to build
a relationship with people if you're not
the one thinking or talking or I'm all
over this be a human write copy like a
human be personal wordss in all okay all
the mess ups and typos and stuff maybe
clean it up a little bit but you get
what I'm saying just be you write your
own stuff don't Outsource it we don't
appreciate it nobody wants to read any
more AI generated content on their feed
or in their emails don't waste your time
so if you're one of those guys get off
the leave okay leave and that will wrap
us up to maximum number five which is
fans over followers I mentioned a little
bit earlier publish over perfect which
means you're emailing on a daily basis
and when you're emailing on a daily
basis you're going to get the
unsubscribes and it hits the ego you're
like oh no but don't worry about it okay
because you're not building a massive
list of a bunch of followers a bunch of
lukewarm people who kind of like you but
don't I mean they're like kind of into
what you do but not really no okay in
Revelation in the Bible Jesus talks
about this he was condemning the
churches for being lukewarm he would say
spit the lukewarm out I don't want it
you're either hot or you're cold and we
treat our email list the same way you're
either hot or you're cold okay and if
you're cold get out of here don't worry
about it I'm going to keep sending my
email but if you're hot and you want it
you're going to be in you want to be in
I learned this the very interesting way
actually pulled my email list of about a
thousand people I pulled them and I said
what would happen if I started sending a
weekly email would you a prefer it would
you B beg me to send daily emails back
or would you see not care it all I was
very interested I was actually nervous
to send this email because I was like oh
no these people are going to be like
dude stop sending emails over 80% of my
list who responded said daily emails
please do not stop your daily emails and
that's because they are fans and you
build that over time so don't worry
about the followers who unsubscribe from
your email list let them go bye you're a
goat to certain people on that list to a
lot of people on that list you can only
do that by building relationships which
you can only do by publishing every day
sending those ugly emails from your
voice and not chat GPT and that is how
you become an email go all five maxims
we smashed it today heck yeah before you
go I have a gift for you if you haven't
already got my copy Cy writing Catalyst
which is Free by the way you could get
in the description below and hit the
link and go ahead and get copyrighting
catalist which is 63 cash cow
copyrighting tips that you can read each
in 90 seconds or less and Implement
today to make your copy better I can't
believe this is free I got to start
charging for this but no go ahead grab
it jump on there we appreciate it also
one last thing one last thing like And
subscribe before you head out please it
helps a channel so so much and it lets
me know that you want more content like
this I hope this helps I'll catch you on
the next one see you I have um I have a
Spider-Man he sits in my I have him in
the back he sits in my office and he
watches my office for me he's just like
looking out just like looking out there
for like Rhino or like Green Goblin just
the Green Goblins that try and get in my
office I can't stand what people try and
get in my office m